yeah I'm gonna yeah I have Magnus here  and among those it you had a chance to  take a draw earlier in this game you  chose not to did you regret that as time  was counting down yeah a little bit  um I mean  when he played  um when he played this little trick with  E6 and queen c6i  I was I was uh that was a lesson  um but um yeah when I chose not to for  us to draw I I thought  um you know I I'm done I'm not risking a  lot I can force the draw later and  didn't really feel the feel the danger  when  when suddenly was there uh so that was  that was of course a little bit shaky  but I think I pulled myself together and  defended okay after that did you ever  feel in real danger of losing that game  on that point  no no I mean  momentarily but after the dust kind of  settled I thought I was fine aggression  or safeness in the last game  I'll say I haven't thought about it good  luck thank you